god creates dinosaurs god destroys
dinosaurs
god creates man
man destroys god
man creates dinosaurs
dinosaurs
eat man
woman inherits the earth
when we made the first jurassic park
movie i was aware that we were creating
a character that was unusual in an
action film
it was important to stephen and myself
that ellie was a feminist female action
character
and your own mother
look
we can discuss sexism in survival
situations when i get back dr ellie
sattler was such an iconic character and
such an important character because
she's a scientist and paleobotanist
it was really important to see an
inspiring character like that as a young
person it felt really exciting that that
became a takeaway for people who loved
the film she's badass and physically
strong and complicated and funny i would
say that for all the female characters
in this franchise
stone cold i would not mess with her i
adore
that there are so many female characters
who are different because we're not all
what would typically present a strong
feminine or a superhero in classic
adventure films it's so important to
have these female role models maisy as a
character has grown up with claire as a
mother who's like really strong and
inspiring
ellie who's so intellectual and clever
and really powerful the wonders
character kayla who's a pilot like super
fierce and tough
still got it it's been really amazing to
work with such strong independent women
i feel beyond honor to join this
franchise from inception it's had great
roles for women but have a degree of
character development and depth and
that's what i saw in kayla you're
willing to risk your life for people you
never met you want to ask questions are
you on the ride jurassic is a very
pro-female
franchise as it started all the
dinosaurs were female they were women
and they're inherent in the idealization
of that female strength female power
hold on tight
i like saying woman inherits the earth
i really like that
[Music]
[Music]
you